Okay, why did no one tell me?
Yesterday I showed you my crossbody bag,
and I told you there's something that I loved about
that no other crossbody bag has.
And then my video cut out.
Don't know what happened, but I didn't get to show you my favorite part.
Okay, I know that it doesn't look like it on here,
but I am a very small human.
I am 5 foot tall, less than 100 pounds,
and I'm an easy target when I'm not about my kids.
Except when I'm wearing this crossbody bag.
The reason why I love it. I showed you all the compartments yesterday,
how much space it has. But my absolute favorite thing about this bag
is this pocket right here,
because it is big enough to conceal whatever it is you need to conceal
to protect you and yourself when you're out with your kids.
Whatever that looks like for you.
I know that is for our family.
But it is so perfect. It fits everything I need when I'm out and about,
and it has an easy access spot.
So if you are also a mom who likes to,
you know, be conscious about her whereabouts
and what she does when she's out and about her kids,
you need this crossbody bag.